We've been talking about core Hadoop. Which consists of HDFS
and map reduce but since the project was first started, an
awful lot of other software has grown up around it. And
that's what we call the Hadoop Ecosystem. Some of the software
is intended to make it easier to load data into
the Hadoop cluster. Well lots of it designed to make Hadoop
easier to use. For example as you'll see in the next
lesson. Writing Map reduced code isn't completely simple. You need to
know a programming language such as Java, Python, Ruby or
Perl. But there are lots of folks out there who
aren't programmers, but can write SQL queries to access data
in a traditional relational database system, like SQL Server. And,
of course, lots of business intelligence tools one way to
hook into Hadoop. For that reason, Other open source projects
have been created to make it easier for people to
query their data without knowing how to code. Two key ones
are Hive and Pig. Instead of having to write
macros and reducers, in Hive you just write statements
like this. Which looks very much like standard SQL.
The Hive interpreter turns the SQL into map produced code,
which then runs on the cluster. And an alternative
is Pig, which allows you to write code to
analyse your data in a fairly simple scripting language,
rather than map reduce. Again the code is just turned
into map reduce and run on a cluster. Hive and Pig are great, but they're still
running map reduce jobs. Which as you'll see
can take a reasonable around of time to run.
Especially over large amounts of data. So another
open source project, is called Impala. Impala was developed
as a way to query your data with
SQL, but which directly accesses the data in HDFS.
Rather than needing map reduce. Impala is
optimized for low latency queries. In other
words Impala queries run very quickly, typically
many times faster than Hive, while Hive
is optimized for running long batch processing
jobs. Another project used by many people
is Sqoop. Sqoop takes data from a
traditional relational database, such as Microsoft SQL Server.
And, puts it in HDFS, as the limited
files. So, it can be processed along with other
data on the cluster. Then, there's Flume. Which
injests data as it's generated by external systems. And,
again, puts it into the cluster. HBase is
a real time database, built on top of HDFS.
And there's more. Hue is a graphical front end
to the questor. Oozie is a workflow management tool.
Mahout is a machine learning library. In fact
there are so many ecosystem projects that making
them all talk to one another, and work
well, can be tricky. To make installing and maintaining
a cluster like this easier, Cloudera, the company
we work for, has put together a distribution
of HADOOP called CDH. CDH or the Cloudera
distribution including a patchy HADOOP, takes all the key
ecosystem projects, along with HADOOP itself, and packages them
together so that installation is a really easy process. And
the components are all tested together, so you can
be sure there's no incompatibilities between them. Of course, it's
free and open source, just like Hadoop itself. While
you could install everything from scratch, it's far easier to
use CDH, and that's certainly what we'd recommend. In
the next lesson, in fact, you'll be downloading and running
a virtual machine, which has CDH installed. For more information on the
Hadoop ecosystem and how each of
these components works, see the instructor notes.